[Music]
so many people know you as the comedy
guy which you still are but you're a
really good actor and you clearly work
at it you clearly like like like you I'm
told anyway that you know season 2
starts with you working at Cinnabon yeah
and this is something that in comedy you
just go and you do a joke about working
Cinnabon you actually learned how to
make a real Cinnabon isn't that right I
learned exactly how you make a Cinnabon
Debbie Rowley taught me she's the lady
from the head office
mrs. Rowley and she came and and that's
part of Vince Gilligan's you know
attention to detail which you should
really know if you're gay you shouldn't
pretend you're my house and mine you
should really Saul should really know
how to do it and he did and I did and I
learned how to make a Cinnabon I had not
only learned the first season but the
second season they gave me a fright
refreshing course and I know what goes
into Cinnabon and I'm not going to tell
you so they you can still enjoy them but
you know you know honestly Cinnabon is
like they're not hiding anything yeah
like this is completely extra in your
life and and so they're not embarrassed
or even the secretive about it know what
they're so although all the stuff you're
not supposed to eat put in one place and
then heat it up and then in there
they're not like filled with fiber
you